Chúng kênh Cui Già liên quân mùa bài đấu trường dành phọng mùa sơn 2 nhìn không chào mạm sấu sẽ được tổ chức
khoảng ai 1 mười tháng 6 tới tại nhà thì đấu đang năng tình quán đình.
Bởi mức quy mù ăn tự.
Và được xem là sự kiện esports đáng chuyện nhất trong tháng 6.
Lần đầu tiên tại đấu trường dây vọng, Mô Sơn Khấu esports sử dụng công nghệ
bà đề mẹp tình lớn nhất Việt Nam sẽ chính thức giảm ắt, với mức đầu tư kỷ lục.
Nhà phó hành kỷ vọng, sẽ có thể tả hiện một mình về nguồn tất,
phíanh bản ngoài đời thực tử khả giả.
Mọi công trên mũi cò, giống xông xông của chiến trường liên quân mùa bài, sẽ được tạo nên
với những hiệu ở nãy sáng ảo dự.
Tụi hệ mạo đến mô tránh nghiệp tỷ giá vô cùng ở tượng.
Hôm giản hùng vi, xân khấu được lâu từ hoành trắng, sẽ giúp chung cách đấu trường dây vọng
vô xuân 2 gỷ cộng 2 bài xấu, cho thành mùa suốt kệ esports, đáng chuyện,
và được quan tâm nhất trong tháng 6.